è arrivato il nuovo Predator Elios neo
16 un PC compatto il dotato di un
processore Intel Core 9 di tredicesima
generazione possiede una nuova
architettura ibrida ad altre prestazioni
è un display antiriflesso LCD 16 decimi
grazie alla scheda grafica Nvidia G
Force rtx 4070 propone un'esperienza
grafica mozzafiato perde le sessioni
gaming come non l'avete mai viste ma
nonostante questo tiene sempre la
temperatura sotto controllo grazie alla
tecnologia all'avanguardia è una
tecnologia con ventola Herobrine quinta
generazione a 89 Lame interamente in
metallo e infine sul retro dello schermo
ci sono dei misteriosi codici che potete
decifrare decifrandoli potreste scoprire
i segreti più nascosti del nuovo
Predator Elios neo 16